[Music]
we're kicking it off with rodolfo in
salem oregon rodolfo welcome to the
ramsay show how are you
pretty good on yourself doing great how
can we help today
so yeah uh my question is uh
six grand in credit card loan debt uh
i was just trying to see where should i
start off
should i pay off at once
uh little by little
you know i'm just i just want to say
where do i start basically so let me
recap you've got six thousand dollars in
credit card debt is this across multiple
cards
uh two cards two cards
okay
are you familiar with with our baby
steps that we teach
uh a little not
i mean i know it's a
one thousand dollar emergency uh
you know for just in case something
happens yeah do you have that so far do
you have a thousand
yeah i do yeah i have more than that you
have more than that how much more are we
talking
i have about eight grand
hold up you have eight grand in cash and
you have six grand in credit card debt
yeah this is an easy math equation for
me what's what's been holding you back
from just going ahead and paying that
whole thing off in one lump sum
well basically you know i i bought this
travel trailer as well
i'm remodeling it so basically it's
gonna cost me about four grand to
gonna be like what's that zero after
that
so you've been hanging on to it for the
remodel
yeah yeah i'm i'm just basically yeah
that
that's what's been holding me holding me
up basically okay and this is your only
debt this credit card debt
i have a car as well i took a i bought a
truck
okay what's what's the loan on that
truck
uh right now it is 26. io26
well you've got baby step one down which
is that thousand dollar starter
emergency fund and now you're in baby
step two where you're paying off all of
your consumer debt uh except the house
and this includes the truck too so what
i would start with is your smallest debt
first that's what we teach the debt
snowball
so you're going to list all of your
debts from smallest to largest we're
ignoring the interest rate we're not
concerned with that we are concerned
with progress and we are concerned with
actually seeing this debt gone so as of
today you could have no credit card debt
with the cash you have on hand correct
yeah correct that'll leave you with two
thousand dollars you can take one
thousand of that and start attacking
that truck loan
and i want that thing gone before you
start doing all these renovations on on
the trailer i mean is there any urgency
around the trailer renovations
uh not too much i just wanted to flip it
so yeah basically okay so this was a
quick money-making scheme for you
just kind of flip the truck make some
money
yeah okay well before before we do that
we got to clean this up
so rodolfo let's put a new timeline
together okay george told you exactly
what to do are you tracking as to why
you need to do it that way and that it
is something you're going to do is that
a yes are you going to do this
the do what
the debt snowball the debt snowball what
george just told you to do you got to
pay that debt off today
yeah well that's the thing so i should i
should pay it often that's what you
recommend yes
absolutely i mean
how much is this truck worth i'm curious
uh
right now it's worth about 42. it's
worth 42 and you have a 26 000 loan
yeah
what do you think about selling that
truck since you're not underwater on it
and using that cash to
really get your life started
well i i thought about that i do
as well
so you need it for your business
yeah no you don't you don't need a 42
000 truck that's a nice truck for a
landscape
i know that you know but no no no hold
on a second hold on a second i'm not in
a butt mood today all right i'm just
gonna jump in here george all right yeah
listen to me dude
let's just run the math
you owe 26 on the truck it's worth 42.
if i heard that correctly i'd flip that
by the weekend that's 16 grand
now you got 16 grand you can go buy
something a decent older truck or
whatever that you need for the 16 and
you can flip the trailer and everything
else and now you're rocking and rolling
man and we're talking about fast
forwarding here we got a point there you
got a point there what i'm hearing is
you could be debt free this week if you
wanted to yeah and then you can be cash
flowing these renovations get a cheaper
truck for the landscaping gig and
upgrade yeah as you get more cash flow
in and let me remind you once you get
rid of that car loan and these credit
cards you're going to have more income
you're going to get a raise because
you're not making payments anymore
that's true so i want that to fuel you
get you excited about the future because
i can tell you're a sharp dude
entrepreneurial type and you're going to
set yourself up way better for the
future if you can clean this mess up
this week and start to have that cash
flow back in your life
okay yeah i think i'm i'm going to do
that for sure probably
try to try taking my truck to carmax or
something to see what they yeah dude
absolutely there's so many options right
now carmax dealerships vroom carvana you
name it but get the best uh bang for
your buck there and uh we believe in you
man you got this you can get rid of this
debt get these uh this income back in
your life that is the key